there's the chemical makeup of the
classic psychedelics you see they all
have the same fundamental structure this
is serotonin that's the one of the major
brain neurotransmitters and so what
happens with the psychedelics is that
they they alter the they alter the brain
function by altering the neurochemical
utilization of serotonin
they changed the manner in which the
serotonergic systems work and the
serotonin system is a very basic system
because when you're an embryo and your
brain is developing it's the serotonin
projections that basically orchestrate
the development of your brain so they're
and they're very archaic circuits very
very archaic circuits so and this is the
paper I think I stole this from
psilocybin Griffiths who's been doing a
lot of this research psilocybin can
occasion mystical type experiences
having substantial and sustained
personal meaning and spiritual
significance so why that's a good
question right like so so here's a
question for you
it is beyond dispute that human beings
are capable of religious experience why
why is that exactly and like you can
associate it with psychosis but that
doesn't work as the theory doesn't hold
a theory doesn't hold water it's not the
same thing so why is it there exactly
and it's not an easy thing to figure out
like I've been trying to figure I'm
always trying to figure out a biological
explanation for everything right because
if you want to find something to stand
on you want to make sure that it can
resist a challenge and so if I can find
an explanation for something that's
reductionistic and materialistic and
biological then I'm going for that
that's a tough one
consciousness is a tough one the the
moral sense is a tough one they're not
easy things to crack the Big Bang is a
tough one so you know I mean a cynic
might say that maybe sometimes when
people are close to suicide they'll have
a mystical experience you know and you
maybe you say well it's a last-ditch
attempt of your brain to delude you into
thinking that your life has some
significance you know and that's a
plausible theory but
I don't think it counts for the
generality of the phenomena so so I
don't buy it